welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show I'm filling in for David for
the rest of the week I hope you've
enjoyed what we've done so far because
I've enjoyed presenting to you this next
story is very serious and something that
Democrats and voting rights
organizations and civil liberty
organizations across the country need to
pay attention to immediately in North
Carolina the Trump administration is
targeting 44 counties and demanding not
just demanding they have subpoena the
records of these counties from 2015
I'm sorry 2013 all the way to August of
2018 a request that is going to [ __ ]
the administration process of early
voting coming up to the midterms a
request that is being issued by the
Department of Justice and ice which is
going to have a chilling effect on
voters legitimate voters who might
happen to be immigrants this is a very
intentional effort by the administration
by the Trump administration to stifle
voter turnout absolutely no other way to
interpret this but I want to read you a
couple of quotes from the article that
was published and broken by it the story
was broken by Mother Jones and this is
what they said first quote state
election officials say the move will
overwhelm their resources and prevent
them from preparing for early and
absentee voting it for the November
midterms and that's the entire point
because traditionally early voting leans
towards the left leans towards
democratic party the Democratic Party
and the request itself is targeting
people who are going to who have who
have questions about their ability to
freely participate in this system you're
not gonna find people like that on the
conservative side of the aisle they are
the most entitled people in this country
but you're gonna have minorities who are
second guessing whether or not they want
to really mess with the system and
that's exactly what this is designed to
do to depress the turnout this is
another quote from mother's Joneses
according he said quote once a penis
into 44 County election boards last week
asked for any and all poll books Ipoh
books voting records and/or voter
authorization documents and executed
official ballots including absentee
ballots from August 2013 to 2018 it went
on to say another subpoena asks the
State Board of Elections for all voter
registration applications along with
documents including absentee ballots and
early voting forms for every county in
the state over the past eight years and
you would think that conservatives would
jump on this and say this is an
intrusion right into states rights and
to their ability to carry out elections
which is their localized and state right
to do but again that's being naive and
arguing within the facts because we have
to understand who we're dealing with
we're dealing with people who absolutely
without question will break every rule
will break every law would deny every
truth would rewrite history in order to
get one political win so that to me it
seems it seems like a futile effort to
argue in the framework of reasonable
times because we're not dealing with
reasonable times and we're not dealing
with reasonable people in reasonable
times conservatives will look at this
and say this is a power grab from the
federal government intruding on the
state rights to carry out their
elections but we're not dealing with
that we're dealing with exactly what I
just described I'm going to read another
quote from Mother Jones we are deeply
concerned by the administrative drain on
county boards and this is again they're
quoting the County Board of Elections
they're in North Carolina quote we are
deeply concerned by the administration
administrative drain on our county
boards of Elections in order to comply
with the extensive subpoenas immediately
prior to a federal election including
the necessary reproduction of millions
of documents I
one estimate that it could be upwards of
15 million documents that they have to
turn over based on this subpoena that
comes from the Department of Justice and
immigration Customs Enforcement last but
not least civil rights groups say the
fraud charges and new subpoenas could
intimidate eligible voters particularly
immigrants into staying home in November
they compared the request for the voting
rights records to a June 2017 request by
Trump's now-defunct election integrity
commission for a sensitive voter data
from all 50 states they couldn't get it
done that way so now they're doing it
this way
again I've already described exactly
what we're dealing with who these people
are but I just want to show you how far
they would go this entire move is based
on this press release from the
Department of Justice and I want you to
listen to the language this fear that
they're trying to instill across the
nation over a straw man a bogeyman that
does not exist not that anybody man
exists but you get the point they're
trying to make a problem that doesn't
exist so that they can offer a solution
that benefits them politically and this
is how they accomplish this look at this
headline it says
fraudsters in Eastern North Carolina
beware
US Immigration and Customs Enforcement
Homeland Security Investigations has
identified Raleigh as an expansion site
to create a new document and benefit
fraud task force this is nothing more
than right-wing propaganda that serves
two purposes to instill fear into
legitimate voters even if they are
immigrants and to instill fear into
their support base so that they can
continue to carry out these draconian
policies